[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday August 29th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
for more than 20 years if you wanted to
find information on the internet you
Googled it there are other search
engines of course but Google is the one
that became a verb now that Trend seems
to be shifting millions of people
especially young people are turning to
tick tock for answers like why would I
Google something and I can go on Tech
talk watch a 15 second video gives me
the full Lowdown on how to make
something if something's good how do you
so Tick Tock is legit better than Google
for a lot of things like go to The Tick
Tock search bar and search how to cut a
watermelon you're going to find 500
videos that are insanely better than
anything you'd find on Google anything
you can imagine you can find on Tick
Tock and not only can you find it quick
but you can find it in video form now I
know I am but how trustworthy are the
answers you might find on Tick Tock and
what does Google think of this trend
Cordelia James reported on this for the
Wall Street journal's personal Tech Team
and she joins us now hey Cordelia thanks
for being here hi Zoe thank you so much
for having me okay so more people are
turning to tick tock to find answers but
what kinds of questions are they asking
yeah so an internal survey at Google
found that like 40 of young people so
people between the ages of like 18 and
24 are using tiktok as a source of
information for all kinds of things some
examples like Fitness ideas fashion
inspiration things to do places to go
travel food recommendations recipes all
kinds of things that you can find on an
app that gives you a lot more visual
results than like a typical Google
search as well as something that's like
super quick and fast
I mean some of those questions seem like
things you might already turn to social
media for you know what to do on a
weekend or fashion tips should Google be
worried so Google actually doesn't have
too much to worry about just yet I would
say mostly because the survey that they
did kind of found that more often than
not people would still use Google in
addition to tick tock however for those
who only rely on Tick Tock as the like
the key source of information that can
be a little Troublesome because not all
of the results that they might get
immediately on the app are always
accurate
okay so what makes it problematic then
for the people who are turning to to
tick tock for information
yeah so tick tock's algorithm gives you
information based on your interests and
what videos are like the most popular at
the time when it comes to those kinds of
videos they don't necessarily always
have to come from reliable sources so if
you're using the app to search for
information such as let's say health
advice but you're not really getting it
from an actual nutritionist then you
might be using some of these skills and
these like tips from someone that might
actually do you more harm than good so
you want to make sure that you're going
off platform to do a little extra
research to make sure you're getting
information from an accurate interested
Source did you find any examples of
where that was happening
so an example of this would be an
avocado hack which was often circulating
around the app and which different users
would see like videos of someone placing
an avocado in a container filled with
water and putting in their fridge and it
was supposedly allowing their avocados
to last a little bit longer without
turning brown however the FDA eventually
had to come out and say that hey that's
actually not really safe due to
pathogens in the water that could
actually cause all kinds of illnesses
you know other social media platforms
have been criticized for the amount of
misinformation that's on their platform
is that something Tick-Tock has to deal
with as well and how was it addressing
that
most definitely so Tick Tock was
actually in the news a lot earlier this
year regarding misinformation
circulating regarding the war in Ukraine
and so after that the app has which mind
you this app is still in its infancy so
this is something that it's still
readily trying to work on and trying to
find ways to address it's just that the
fact that it has like such a strong
influence that makes this really scary
at times but since then the app has
partnered with a bunch of independent
fact checking organizations and make
sure to screen videos even before it
gets on the app as well as when users
report them directly so it's like a team
of between like using technology as well
as real people to make sure that the
information going out there is actually
safe or like not harmful however that
can be really hard it's harder for the
algorithm to pinpoint misinformation
exactly compared to say like a symbol or
something that's inappropriate or
something along those lines so it's
definitely something that they're still
having to work on but the good news is
the that Tick Tock told me that if a
video is deemed false it is removed from
the platform completely if it is true or
doesn't have any harmful misinformation
it stays up but if fact checking is
still underway or if the information is
still unsubstantiated then it won't be
in the for you page but it might still
appear in search so that's something
that you have to make sure that you're
looking out for okay so for the people
who do want to use talk kind of as a
search engine what do they need to bear
in mind when they're looking up
questions
yeah so a few things to keep in mind if
you're using the app as a search engine
think about what it is that you're
trying to use and apply to your actual
everyday life so things such as medical
information or financial information
might have a lot more risk than say
um you just choosing what kind of
restaurant you want to go to but
regardless of it you should make sure
that the videos that you are choosing to
watch are actually from people that you
can trust or organizations that you can
trust Cordelia you spoke to some Tick
Tock users who you know used the
platform to search for information when
you spoke to them were they skeptical of
the kinds of information they found in
these videos or did they just take it at
face value
a lot of people really took things at
face value the people that I spoke to
often it just wasn't really a big
concern for them on the app these are
things that just seem like very everyday
low-risk kind of situations or at least
like they might seem like it because you
might not really feel the need to do any
additional leg work because it's like
while you're on these apps it feels like
you're talking to like a trusted friend
these are creators that you've followed
for extended period of time you probably
trust a lot more you just have to make
sure that you're aware of the fact that
not everything that you hear on Tick
Tock is right and you want to make sure
you're practicing your media literacy
skills to make sure you're getting the
best information also Tick Tock did
mention to me that when it comes to
verified check marks something to just
keep in mind is that that's meant to say
that this person is who they say they
are not necessarily that they are an
expert on whatever topic that they're
talking about
all right that's Cordelia James from our
personal Tech Team thanks for joining us
Cordelia thanks again Zoe
everything
man of the show please take a second to
leave a review and a five star rating it
helps other people find the show and
lets us know you like what we're doing
and if you want more Tech stories check
out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign